داني الفيش لاعب البرازيلي اللي سبق ولعب
في انديه كبيره ابرزها طبعا برشلونه جالس
هو كمان في السجن من 20 يناير من بعد ما
طلعت فتاوى اغتصابها في حمام ملهى ليلي في
برشلونه ثاني وضعه سيء في القضيه لانه
الان مغير اقواله اربع مرات والمحكمه رفضت
اكثر من مره طلبوا بالافراج عنه بكفاله
وزوجته انفصلت عنه وناديه
لكن اليوم وضعه اسوا واسوا من بعد ما طلعت
فتاه بفيديو على تيك توك وقالت انه داني
حاول من 8 سنوات وفي نفس المكان يغتصبها
بنفس الطريق وقالت ان المقربين منها
عارفين القصه من زمان انه في نفس هذه او
في نفس هذا النايت كلوب وعمرها 18 سنه
دعاها داني لمكان البي اي بي وعمل فيها
نفس اللي عملوا فيه الفتاه الثانيه وقالت
انها بتشعر بالاشمئزاز انه بعد ثمانيه
سنوات يرجع دانيه يعمل نفس الشيء الفيديو
انتشر وجاب ملايين مشاهدات وبعدها اختفى
من تيك توك